votre roman m'a vraiment bouleversée
ainsi votre livre m'a donné un espoir
insensé
c'est difficile pour moi ce livre c'est
un pas être simple ce moment que vous
traversez allez un dernier petit effort
pour votre grande admiratrice
c'était comment j'ai rencontré une fille
vraiment intéressante
on a passé la soirée à parler le succès
les commentaires cette lumière soudaine
j'imagine qu'il doit y avoir un risque
d'effondrement vraiment sympa c'était
longtemps que tu écris plus du tout
[Musique]
parfois j'ai l'impression que tous les
stabilise elle va être beaucoup ça
m'inquiète quand même je vais m'occuper
de tout ça te va comme ça
tu vas prendre ça ça va soulager
tous les écrivains s'emparent des faits
divers droite on refuse d'écrire son
livre au cachet encore plus personnel
je ne sais pas quelqu'un qui proposait
sur le toit non non à la remarque très
bon écoute une attention à l'autre via
par décrire ce que tu dois écrire
arrête un bon disque achats
au sol je sais qui tu es
est ce que tu peux écrire
je veux dire une chose j'ai jamais écrit
pour faire plaisir à qui que ce soit et
j'ai pas l'intention de commencer
tu la fermeture responsable de l'amour
que tu as su système
bien sûr pas très loin
tu mets en danger et pourtant cette
vérité là qu'il faut te confronter top
c'est comme si tout s'était éclairée
c'est sur un que je dois écrire
c'est un guide qui a permis à cette
violence de s'exprimer
un jour je te raconterai
elle a mordu à l'hameçon
[Musique]